les mots de la semaine ont été prononcés
par le président sortant Emmanuel Macron
il y a pas de recette magique
le gaz il y a pas de recette magique sur
le pouvoir d'achat on a mis 20 milliards
l'équivalent de 2020 il y a pas d'argent
magique
Emmanuel Macron Renaud donc avec les
déplacements de terrain pour sa campagne
les bains de foule et les
interpellations des Français sans
surprise avec les retraites c'est le
sujet du pouvoir d'achat qui est revenu
le plus souvent et donc il a répondu
avec cette formule il n'y a pas de
recette magique il n'y a pas d'argent
magique cette facilité rhétorique n'est
pas nouvelle elle rappelle par exemple
les mots de Lionel Jospin en 1999 qui a
pris une série de licenciements chez
Michelin avait déclaré il ne faut pas
tout attendre de l'État c'est exactement
le même sens que l'on doit trouver dans
cette formule argent magique d'Emmanuel
Macron d'ailleurs il semblerait qu'elle
soit fabriquée pensée pour lui car c'est
pas la première fois qu'il l'utilise
rappelez-vous en 2018 Emmanuel Macron
déplacement dans un CHU de Rouen a
répondu exactement avec la même réponse
à une aide-soignante qu'il avait Inter
sur le manque de financement de
l'hôpital public mettre des moyens sans
faire les choses qui pour le moderniser
accompagner transformer avoir parfois du
bon sens c'est pas aider les gens parce
qu'à la fin les moyens c'est vous qui
les payez aussi vous savez il y a pas
d'argent magique sauf qu'entre temps
entre cette séquence de 2018 et celle de
lundi à Dijon il y a eu la crise du
covid et la doctrine du quoi qu'il en
coûte l'argent magique d'Emmanuel Macron
est donc difficilement tenable d'autant
plus que depuis une semaine le scandale
du recours abusif au cabinet de conseils
fragilise le candidat d'en marche
recyclé une formule magique qui d'un
certain côté désigne l'électeurs comme
étant un profiteur alors que l'État est
accusé de dépenser trop et donc un
risque à moins de 15 jours du premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle